see most people want it easy if you easy
come easy what easy go what if you live
your whole life only to discover that it
was wrong that it was wrong
what would you like be like as you look
toward the future if you decided I'm not
going to allow my peers to stop me he's
one of the world's most renowned
motivational speakers he mastered the
science of achievement by interviewing
hundreds of successful business leaders
over three decades he received the
golden gavel Award for achievement and
leadership in communication he's Les
Brown and here is my take on his top ten
rules of success volume two and as
always guys as you're watching the
videos if you hear something that really
resonates with you please leave it down
the comments below and put quotes around
it so other people can be inspired as
well also as you are writing something
down it's much more likely to stick in
your head to enjoy
here's what I discovered that happens to
you in life that you will go through
things and while you're going through
them you can't understand why it's
happening to you but after you go
through it you get back and you look at
it and you say oh now I understand why I
needed that lesson have your little
happen to you in turn have ever happen
to you but that I did I couldn't
understand it there but after I got
through it then I saw that that was
prepared me for bigger and better things
but as you go through the challenges of
life and you look at it and embrace
whatever comes to you don't run from it
step toward it don't try and duck it
like most people do see most people want
it easy
if you easy come easy what easy go see
but when you go out what you're going to
deal with and you deal with the
difficult difficulties of it when you
handle those hard things close at hand
making those hard decisions right now
that you don't want to make learning
those things that you don't like to do
but you know that in order for you to
get where you want to go this is one of
the hoops that you have to flip through
and I'm saying to you whatever you got
to do do it because if you don't life is
going to whoop you until you surrender
and say okay all right all right all
right all right I cooperate okay I
learned okay they had to wear me out a
long time so it's hard to do it hard so
going to focus to develop your skills a
guy was with the new owner of a team a
team a baseball team that was in the
basement of the league when he took it
over
he went to the picture and he said what
is your best throat he said well I got a
good curve ball and I've got a good
fastball he went on talking about his
different throws he said but tell me
this what is your best throw he thought
for a moment he thought I've got a good
fastball he said that's all I want you
to work on nothing else just develop
your fastball the next year they went to
the World Series most people don't know
what their fastball is most people go
through life never discovering what
their talents are most people never
develop their talents they have skills
and abilities but if you don't nurture
them if you don't develop them they will
never serve you your gifts can take you
many places if you develop your gear
most of us don't like to do those things
that comes easy to us I've always loved
to talk to people I decided taking this
advice to the
my skills as a seeker and my gift has
developed and it developed and it's
taken me many places you have something
that you brought to the universe and
that if you decide that my life deserves
my developing this what I do well and
becoming the best at it in mastering
myself and seeing what I have within me
if you decide to drop your buckets where
you are and develop your gift I grant
you you will never ever be without I
grant you that your gifts will take you
places that will literally amaze you I
grant you that if you begin to work to
develop your gift your develop a strong
sense of happiness you'll get a larger
vision of yourself because part of
beginning to get a larger vision of
yourself all of us need some area of our
lives where we can have a feeling of
competence that people know when they
think about this area that's something
you do that you even sleep bad and that
you do that you do that and people know
it and you know it and you know that you
know that you know this if you don't
know anything else you know this can you
tell I know I know what I'm doing oh
hello you know this so you've got to
work on it dr. Howard Thurman one of the
mentions of dr. Martin Luther King jr.
and Albert Schweitzer and Mahatma Gandhi
is a very brilliant writer he wrote some
things that really grabs me he he wrote
deep if the hunger the voice of the
genuine the sintering MoMA during the
time after receiving 238 radiation seed
implants I was reflecting on his words
and and these words kept me up that
night he said the ideal situation for a
man a woman to die if they have family
members praying with them
as they cross over he said but imagine
if you will being on your deathbed and
standing around your bed the ghosts of
the dreams the ideas the abilities the
talents given to you by life and that
you for whatever reason you never went
after that dream you never acted on
those ideas you never use those talents
you never to use those gifts and there
they are standing around your bed
looking at you with large angry eyes and
we came to you and only you could have
given us life and now we must die with
you forever and the question is if you
die today what dreams what ideas what
talents what books what music what
leadership what voice will die with you
mouths Monroe great orator and speaker
said the wealthiest place on the planet
it's not an a' for youth where there's
oil in the ground is not it South Africa
whether diamond mines either the
wealthiest place on the planet is the
cemetery but you dare you'll find
practice that we've never seen there you
find talent in genius and potential
never actualized
perhaps that's why Henry David Thoreau
wrote the words all God to reach the
point of death only to realize that
you've never lived maybe that's why some
unknown writer wrote the words what if
you live your whole life only to
discover that it was wrong that it was
wrong that you were chosen to do
something else and you didn't do it and
as you begin to challenge yourself you
discover some things about yourself that
you don't know right now the other thing
is you begin to look at yourself look at
your dreams it and and begin begin to
experiment and stepping in to your
greatness one of the things that's very
important whatever goals and dreams that
you have repeat off me please make your
move before you're ready
yeah price prejudice of a great great
motivator and trainer said make your
move before you're ready we're
instructed in life to walk by faith and
not by sight see you want to really
begin to stretch yourself you want to
become a risk-taker you want to raise
the bar on yourself most people won't do
that see most people engage in low life
living low risk living this cop said if
you're not willing to risk you cannot
grow and if you cannot grow you cannot
become your best and if you cannot
become your best you can't be happy and
if you can't be happy then what else is
there I like what Helen Keller said life
is short and unpredictable eat the
dessert first and so you want to begin
to take some chances you want to begin
to challenge yourself and make it okay
to feel and learn from your failures
don't allow fear of failure and the Lord
the attractiveness of playing it safe in
life to draw you in you can't get out of
life alive you've got to die to leave
here there are a lot of people who are
biting their fingers and fear that they
might lose their jobs but there are few
people who have decided within
themselves I'm going to make it some
people aren't waiting to be cut some
people are moving on their home because
they feel within themselves I've got
what it takes to make it then are afraid
about tomorrow because of how they see
themselves because of what they feel
that they deserve because of what they
feel that they can create for themselves
because these people have decided as
they look at the future as they look at
themselves there's a way whether the
will there's a way for me to begin to
create a way out of no way and when you
have that kind of consciousness when you
have that kind of spirit nothing can
stop you nothing what would your life be
like as you look toward the future if
you
you decided I'm not going to allow my
fears to stop me what would you like be
like what would your future be like if
you decided to to want that which you
desire so strongly that it prepares you
past your fears that you experience the
fear the one book says feel the fear and
do it anyway what would your life be
like and I'm saying to you that all of
us who have been in tuned by fear has a
capacity to resurrect ourselves and to
resurrect our dreams
all of us have a passion today I want
you to look at something right now
thank you some major goal you want or
maybe it's one you're already working on
and you have experienced a lot of
setbacks a lot of defeats you've
experienced a lot of disappointment
maybe you've already given up and maybe
you just need a little far little
encouragement to get back in the game
again here's what I want you to look at
they're winners they're losers and there
are people who have not discovered how
to win and all they need is some
coaching all they need is some help and
assistance just a little support all
they need is some insight or different
strategy a plan of action to make some
adjustment that will open up the key to
a whole new future prevent that will
give them access to the unlimited power
that they have within themselves I
probably need so what I want you to do
is think about something you want for
you that's real for you that's important
for you that will give your life some
special meaning and power and I don't
even want you to say I can do that I
don't want you to assume that see five
years ago when I started out in this
area I would not have been able to make
the mental leap that I would be up to
where
I am right now I don't want you to begin
to just psych yourself out no no I want
you to be able to say something to
yourself that will enable you to
maintain a level of integrity with
yourself that when you say this even
when you face tremendous setbacks it it
will be a benchmark to keep you in the
game to keep you moving forward and
experimenting and readjusting your
strategy and your plan of action
continuously looking for ways to win so
what is that something when you got an
idea you want to move on you might not
have the money you might not have the
education you might not have the support
or the resources you need what is that
something that can keep us going that
will enable us to act on our dream
what's one of those keys that will begin
to help us to discover the secrets to
our dream here's what I want you to
repeat after me please with power and
conviction say it's possible although
once you do when you look at your dream
you say to yourself every day it's
possible let's say that every day to
them it's possible because what does
that do please it begins to change your
belief system so the way in which we
operate ladies and gentlemen it's a
manifestation of what we believe what's
possible for us whatever you've done up
to this point all that it really is is a
duplication it's a reproduction of what
you believe subconsciously that you
deserve and what's possible for your
life before in April 1954 the common
belief the universal belief because it
had been tried again and again and again
and people who failed the belief laws
that man was not physically capable of
breaking the four-minute barrier that he
could not la mile and less informative
that was to believe on the planet it had
never been done but here's what happened
ladies and gentlemen
Roger Bannister came along and he wrote
the four-minute barrier now here's
what's significant about that since that
line up to this day over 20,000 people
have done it including high school kids
what change 20,000 people what changed
here's what happened when they got on
the track they knew it had been gone and
because they knew it had been done there
was a new belief about this barrier
about this goal that was unreachable and
those 20,000 people got into raised
believing knowing in the heart that
someone had done it that it's possible
that they could do it and I'm saying
that if you know anybody that had some
goals some dreams something they wanted
to do and they did it the nice thing
that you know in your heart that if
someone has done it think you can do it
it's possible and that if someone can
make that dream become a reality that
it's possible that you can make your
dream become reality you constantly
remind yourself after every defeat after
every setback every time you get not
done I've got a thing it's life knocks
you down try and land on your back
because if you can look up you can get
up see a lot of people because of
failure they stop they stop believing
let me share something with you
you will fail your way to success yeah
eight out of ten millionaires have been
financially bankrupt you will fail your
way to success it doesn't matter how
many times you fail it doesn't matter
how many times people tell you that you
can't do it it doesn't matter if you
don't have a dime in the Bakke you will
fail your way to success we live in a
world where we're told more about our
limitations rather than our potential
how many have ever been told that you
couldn't do something raise your hands
please your MIT did a study that if I
say to you you can't do that that 16
people have to come alone and say you
can do that you can do that you can do
that to neutralize that and the
seventeenth statement that you hear you
can do it will be the one that will
finally stick
so you have to watch who's speaking in
to you you've got to begin to monitor
your mind and you've got to begin to
literally be proactive in programming
yourself to success be not conformed to
this world being transformed by the
renewing of your mind you've got to take
responsibility to make that happen and
as you begin to do that you'll begin to
see some incredible changes you I've
understand that when arrow nightingales
that all of us are self-made but only
the successful will admit it as you
begin to look at your dreams and look at
your goals write this down make no your
vitamin C most people stop short of
their dreams in park and get off the
highway of life because of the
rejections of life you will always be
rejected it's no big deal
so I can't feel said rejection is a myth
it's not like when somebody says no and
then they flap you know just you know
what to make know your vitamin get
excited about but no why because every
time someone says no that brings you
another step to a yes you're getting
closer trust me you will win if you
don't quit you will win if you don't
quit even a broken clock is Right twice
a day
and so as I begin to work on myself I
realize that I'm getting out of one
story and stepping into another story if
I become aware of some things that still
some things I'm not aware of so I still
I'm still growing I'm still developing
I'm like the ladies in law 8 what a
wannabe eight what I'm going to be but
thank God I show eat what I was but I
realized that that you have to work on
yourself on a regular basis and write
this down for mental mindset for mental
mindset and stamina because things are
going to happen to you
godwyn to the next more necessary to
stop talking to people and seeking and
asking but what I wanted and leveraging
relationship and trying to find out how
do people do it that went ahead of me
how do they do it and then what is it I
need to do how is it I need to train
myself to develop myself
what's the resources that will be
required and
make it happen and as I start seeking
out and asking questions I started
running into people that I know someone
who can help you do that and they helped
me get the nectar with those people
remember we have so much energy that can
take us so far it's necessary that you
hook up with some other energy that can
take you to the next level I hooked up
willingness unless let's go oz it away
we go
and guess what here we are I love you
watch yourself if not there you take
responsibility for now you make it
happen that you don't give up that you
don't take any objection or
disappointment or defeats personally
that you keep on keeping on that you all
decided I can't make it because you
can't see the light at the end of the
toe that you realize that's a part of
the program and here's something you've
got to resolve say this to yourself
every day as long as you believe that
you've got a shot at your dream that's
the way I resolve say this please it's
not over until I will you've got that
right
that'll tell I win not over till I get
flu not over till I get over not over
till I get what I want
door can't open a day to look out I'm
gonna come back and take the hinges off
that's how you got to do that you've got
to have that kind of courage that type
of determination if you want to make it
happen
it's you that you've got to take
personal responsibility to make it
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video to continue in the
volume 2 series I'd love to know what
you guys think and if we should continue
it if you want to nominate somebody else
let me know
I'd also really love to know what did
you learn from les today that had the
biggest impact on you and why what
message are you going to take from him
and immediately apply it to your life
for your business somehow leave it down
the comments below I'm going to joining
in the discussion finally I want to give
a quick shout out to Jay Rhys and links
thank you guys so much for picking up a
copy of my book here one word and that
entry into the contest I love the video
and I really appreciate your support
we're here you will read your unboxing
[Music]
today excited so thank you guys again
for watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon
most people are not accumulating well
most people are living in poverty most
people are living far below their
potential not because they don't have a
capacity not because they have not been
given authority and dominion over
everything on the face of the earth but
most people are living like they're
living because of the fact that they
don't believe they can have anymore than
what they now have the book called The
Miseducation of a Negro gosh astrology
Woodson says if you can determine what a
man shall think you never have to
concern yourself with what he will do if
you can make a man feel inferior you
never have to compel it the secret
imperious status or he will seek it
himself and if you can make a man feel
justly at out half you never have to
order him to go to the back door he'll
go without being told and if there's no
door it's very nature will demand why
that's why scripture reminds us be not
conformed to this world but be
transformed by the renewing of your mind
so every day is you have to sell
yourself and get out of your mind goes
old thought that old belief system every
day you've got to sell yourself on that
it's possible actually got to put a new
mind in you you got to get out of your
mind you got to begin to restructure
your thinking every day you've got to
begin to recondition your mind be many
of us go through life making choices
thinking it's our choices and it's not
you want to make your dream come true
you got to stay focused some people
rather get even than get ahead stay
focus on where you want to go I just
kept on doing what I was supposed to do
and so I was driving to the radio
station my opponent had over $20,000 I
had less than $800 and I was in the
radio station the guy said you want to
make a commercial I said yes is that a
better be a good one because that money
can't go pretty for here
and I said they're in the middle control
room and I was thinking and here's what
happens when you get skilled stuff will
start coming something said call you
mama used to talk about your mother on
the air all the time ask her to say a
few words for you
that would be a different kind of
political spa so I call my mama and I
had a gospel record playing in the
background
and then I had my mother say hello this
is mrs. Mamie bra when I raise my sons I
raise them to be good children when they
got out of hand I beat their behind and
made them go right please both of my son
he's a football
using the state representative race
maybe three or four thousand people will
come out to vote in a primary and that
primary race over 27,000 people came out
and voted said I'm voting for Less
Branca this mod will say he's a good boy
I won ladies and gentlemen i won
so you've got to be willing to say focus
to be creative to be relentless because
things are going to happen to you when
you're working on your dream